so all they're asking us to do here is
find find dy/dx find the derivative so
in some ways you're like what's the big
deal I'm just doing the same thing I did
before if this was F and this is F - yes
it's just another way of labeling the
same process just so long as you know
that it's a different way of thinking
about it
this I should write a bit differently
right it might be handy to write this
not in as a fraction but as what what
kind of things are we good at
differentiating at the moment things
where the X has a power where there's
indices right so instead of a on X I'm
gonna write that as a X to the negative
1 and then here I'm gonna have a X to
the negative 2 happy times so this I can
just apply my rules of differentiation
to write I can say this guy here I'm
going to come on you guys think I'm
about to do with the negative 1 what's
gonna happen to it it's going to I'm
gonna multiply the whole thing by the
current power
ok and then what happens to the power
after I've done that it reduces by 1 so
this is going to become X to the
negative 2 I'm going to rinse and repeat
over here but my power slightly
different so I'll multiply by negative
tooth the a is still there and then the
power reduces by 1 which gives me this
are you happy with that answer
you have differentiated before you ask
to do is find the derivative this is the
derivative however I have a minor kind
of preference to change this back into
fraction form because that's the form
they handed it to me in so I'm going to
write this as negative a on x squared
minus 2a on X cubed are you happy with
that it doesn't matter that we haven't
factorized out the a it doesn't matter
not really it might be useful to
factorize it later on depending on what
you're going to do with this derivative
but we will get to that a bit later on
because there's no context you know what
what does simplest mean if there's no
context or there's it could be factorize
it could be expanded because you have no
context you don't know okay so that's
fine now Chloe asked me a question
to follow up on this I need some space
over here which was that if you have a
look at the original question this guy
here the original function right it
looks like it kind of begs to be
factorized right before you start
differentiating you can see for example
that a we would just talk about you can
factorize that out you would end up with
a outside of what am I gonna be f with
this is the original function 1 over X
plus 1 over x squared so you can
factorize that this is kind of nice
because you can just treat these objects
you can differentiate them just like you
did before
but a the constant at the front doesn't
really affect things so cool that looks
good but the way I've written it it
looks like it begs to be factorized
again doesn't it what's another fact you
can pull out of this that there's a
common factor of 1 over X in here right
so it's tempting to do this take out
that factor of whatever X what does it
leave you with one plus one over X ok
yeah this is tempting to do but as it
turns out something goes awry if you try
and differentiate it as it is at the
moment let's actually see what happens
I'm gonna write this in a different
color to indicate that what I'm about to
do is wrong but let's just see what
happens anyway because it's actually a
really important mathematical thing to
do just see what happens when you try
something even if it ends up being wrong
let's see how much of this we can do in
our heads so this first thing here a
over X is a X to the negative one this
guy I already know how to differentiate
that right so I'm just gonna write it as
negative a X to the negative two you're
happy with that that's from there okay
and then I just keep on proceeding
through just like we did over here just
going from left to right okay I've got
brackets what happens to this one it
just disappears why does it disappear by
the way why can I just disregard it
good so your first reason why is to say
oh that's X to the pound zero right but
that's a bit of an issue in terms of
like what happens that power that
negative one it doesn't matter cuz I'm
multiplying by zero there's another
reason I want to remind you though think
back to the first thing that we wrote
here right differentiating is trade you
find that gradient function right tell
me what's the gradient of one what is
one does that look like
here's your Cartesian plane and here is
y equals one right as a great new zero
that's why you know it's not just a rule
these things disappear it's because the
gradient will be zero okay last piece
over here one over X this is X to the
negative one so it can tell me the
derivative negative x to the negative
two okay let's see what I can do with it
I have some negatives to cancel out I
also have some terms who I can use index
laws to combine looks like I end with an
A to the times X to the negative 4 yeah
are you happy with my index laws now
this this doesn't look good right so my
question to you is why is this a problem
why don't we end up on the same answer
does anyone know the reason why it
doesn't work out because one of the
great things that Matz is you can solve
problems by looking at different methods
and coming to the same solution why
doesn't it work
okay over x squared yep
yes true that's really good intuition
yes so what's going on here right we
know did you have you been taught this
like it also a mnemonic device the
derivative of a sum this is a sum
something possibly else the derivative
is sum is the sum of the derivatives you
just look at each one independently and
I could have like there's two here I
could have 200 things I could just
differentiate them all one at a time
just like guys suggest I could separate
them out quite nicely okay the
derivative of a sum is the sum of the
derivatives but the derivative of a
product the derivative of a product is
not simply the product of the
derivatives it just kind of explodes
right you can demonstrate this really
easily just by looking at really simple
ones right again right this Anika's
gonna be wrong but if I differentiate it
something like x squared okay now just
quickly note how am I using the
differential operator here I haven't
introduced something called Y but this
is like my Y it's just my function okay
so I'm differentiating that just be
careful you remember I said before oh
it's not just like a it's not just like
a fraction some people look at this and
they say oh I know what to do here
cancel cancel cancel cancel yay
not-not-not yay okay so now we know
though what to do with this you tell me
what to do what is the to do comes out
the front and then power reduces by one
so there it is okay but think about what
happens if we write this as a product
and try to differentiate right well
differentiate X multiplied by X what's
the derivative of the first x1 what's
the derivative of the second x1 that's
that's also looking really bad okay so
so this doesn't work right it's
internally inconsistent if we try things
like this the derivative of a product is
not the product of the derivatives which
is why some of you already have
encountered something we call the
product rule which is rather more
complicated and you're like oh I have to
learn this complicated thing because the
simple thing doesn't work right
it's completely false